Hello everybody, this is Dr. Kevin Connors, and this is episode 9 of my personal journey.
I'm tidally this, the dark night of the soul.
I know everybody has dark nights of the soul, nights that you're struggling with the
reason why of everything, how to pray, how to search for meaning in all of what's going
on in your life.
I have those times too, and during those times I can fall back on the truth that I serve
a sovereign God, and even when I don't know what's going on, I can trust him, and that's
what gives me comfort.
Just know that I can crawl up on his lap and have him just stroke my hair and rub my
belly and tell me everything is going to be okay, and I don't need to know why, I don't
need to know when, I don't need to know what that he's my daddy, and he loves me enough
and I need to trust him in that.
So even through my struggles and my dark nights in the soul, God gives me comfort to continue
on just knowing that I can trust him through it all.
Well one of the ways God uses me, or at least how he speaks to me, is he gives me words
to write.
I'm not an artist, I can't paint beautiful pictures and I'd give meaty to that, but he gives
me poems, as much cordia as they seem to other people maybe, that's just how he speaks to me
and how he comforts me, and I'm going to share one with you that I just wrote last night,
but it was a dark night in my soul, up in pain and couldn't sleep, just struggling through
those same questions that you all have, and trusting and falling into his lap at the end,
because he's my daddy, and he loves me more than anything, and I can trust that without
knowing everything.
So this little poem that he gave me is called, should I pray for healing?
Should I pray for rest?
What I pray for wisdom, should I ask you for what's best?
Should I pray for others to make their bodies whole?
Should I ask for physical or more to heal the soul?
I pray that you take of me the deepest part to be refined, protect my wife, my family, Lord,
I pray for all I'll leave behind when I wide in anger and what a pity cry.
I ask your Holy Spirit to bring right words to your side, for I don't know how, and I don't
know why, and I don't understand your ways, and I don't even know how to try, but simply
surrender, I fall before your feet, for I'm holy, your Lord, there's nothing more in
me, just glorify your name, in the I pray, glorify your name, I pray, and hold me in your
arms, and tell me all, will be okay, all will be okay, and that's the comfort that I
know that God loves you, and me, and He just wants to hold us sometimes, and hush us in
our sadness, and tell us everything is going to be okay, it's going to be okay.